it's a spirit of Amazon which is always
it's the one at Amazon
day one is a state of mind Amazon starts
from the customer so whatever we
building we are building something to
solve a hard customer problem or
delightful feature for the customer so
you should think about that ok you're
not gonna be building something which is
nobody's gonna use so there is fashion
domain there home security and there are
other domains we're working on so you
will get an opportunity to work on a
whole suit of different domains and
areas and that basically becomes a
highly exciting opportunity things we
ship it's pretty much kind of tip of the
iceberg there been a lot of technology
development science development and some
projects have failed but what they've
enabled us to do is to actually become
stronger understand our failures faster
so this whole concept of fail fast in
Amazon is just amazing there is no
limits to who you can reach out to or
you know there's this cool technology
which is very different from what we do
but there is no problem to try it out
and see if it fits well so and and if I
want to develop a new thing there's
always that's always welcome so you
don't find resistance you can always
play with whatever idea you want to
publishing is important in on many many
levels scientists want to be able to get
their work critiqued and share it with
the community and stuff so the more we
publish we are going to get better
scientists scientists were motivated to
have impact through products but also
bring out the next innovation so we
don't go out of our way to again find
and invent problems just for publishing
publishing is a natural outcome of what
we're doing the career paths for
computer vision scientists is what we
have seen so far is they're doing great
works you get promoted to the next level
as you go up and you get promoted you
get more responsibilities and more
ownership to more complex issues and as
I said you get not only to implement but
to actually influence and not just
within 80
you get to influence across teams it's a
great time to be part of vision and AI
in general the deep learning and how
we're at the speed at which we are
solving solutions is amazing for me I'm
very clearly driven and I feel motivated
actually challenged I feel like I grow
every day it's very fulfilling and
Amazon is I think the best place for me
to do that we are building something
that is not there we have to invent and
you know this is a wonderful opportunity
to push the envelope and to advance a
state of the art which is what
scientists are all about
[Music]
hello cvpr good morning good afternoon
good evening depending on your time zone
welcome to this virtual cvpr I am
Jeetendra Malik it's my pleasure today
to interview and conduct this fireside
chat with Charlie Bell Charlie Bell is
senior vice president at Amazon Web
Services this is something very well
known to us in computer vision we have
all used Amazon Mechanical Turk for
annotations and we have used AWS for our
compute needs so it's a great thrill to
be interviewing him and I hope that we
will get some insights from this
interview which will be of interest to
the computer vision community at large
so a few words about Charlie Charlie is
a bonafide a computer scientist and a
rocket scientist he started off in his
early in his career he worked with NASA
he worked on Space Shuttle he worked on
the Hubble Space Telescope and then he
was one of the early people who joined
Amazon and was responsible for much of
the work in infrastructure there so with
that I'd like to get Charlie to to to
answer a few questions but first of all
thank you very much Charlie for taking
the time I think the computer vision
community appreciates a WSS involvement
and contribution to our field and I
thank you for take
that time today yes we very much
appreciate the community thank you and
so perhaps we before we get started
maybe you could tell us a little bit
more about yourself
yeah Sondra I started out in Amazon and
1998 when Amazon was just selling books
I came into the company we were very
small aqua hire and my boss asked me
what do you want to do and I said well
I'll do whatever nobody else wants to he
said well go build customer service
applications so I started working on
that and then a few months into it he
said hey I need you to run the
infrastructure here so I went over to
that job and that was absolutely a joy I
did that for five years and we were in a
whole period of get big fast and we were
scaling Amazon and having a lot of fun
in 2006 I decided I want to try
something new and there was this small
operation up on the hill called Amazon
Web Services we were just building it
we'd actually launched at that time we
actually launched Mechanical Turk
interestingly enough it was one of the
very first Amazon Web Services that
wasn't related to the retail business
and so I joined the team in 2006 when we
were just getting started with ec2 and
s3 and so that's been 14 years of pure
fun and we really enjoyed it and we got
very deep into machine learning Amazon's
always use machine learning by the way
when I joined we were using it in
personalization and certainly the
computer vision state of space opened up
all kinds of opportunity for us so AWS
has done quite a bit in that space and
thrilled to be three here talking to you
wonderful thank you very much so maybe
we can get started by talking about
Amazon's investments in computer vision
what's driving your investment in
computer vision and how's Amazon
applying it to the business well as I
said
computer vision started to have a pretty
big impact on our business a while ago
in 2013 we embarked on this idea of
reinventing the way people shop we'd
always had ideas about playing it to our
heart fulfillment world we we began
working on Amazon go back then and one
of the interesting challenges was to
figure out a way to do just walk out
where people could walk into a store
pick something up they wanted and and
walk out of the store not have to go
through any headache of checkout and so
there was that and then and there was
other work we were doing that was very
inspiring inside the company and we saw
lots of applications coming and so AWS
began investing in the computer vision
because their customers were starting to
ask questions about it and asked us if
we could help them solve problems we
read up to that point we've been really
focused on the whole idea of
democratizing AI the idea that you you
have a very small number of super
capable intelligent practitioners who
could who could apply machine learning
to various problems but the world was
going to need tools that would allow the
average person to get access to it so
how could the average software developer
or even non software developer have
access to machine learning and be able
to do things with this fabulous new
technology so you know we spent a lot of
time thinking about you know where we
wanted to invest our time we realized
that this would be all up and down the
stack that we'd need to invest in
hardware we didn't need you invest in
software most importantly we need to
invest in tools that would make it easy
to get access to machine learning and
especially for folks that weren't deeply
trained so you have the deep prep
practitioners of it and then you have
other folks that would want to apply it
to things and so we wanted to support
the entire
community of people that would be doing
things with machine learning and we also
saw computer vision as a super
interesting area and likewise begin
building that up the stack so building
tools to give people the raw access to
frameworks all the way up to having
inference services where you could just
feed it some pictures and then say
what's in my picture and so there was a
great a great need of course in the
computer vision space to do annotation
and if I kind of wind the clock back to
what we did with Mechanical Turk back in
2005 and we launched it it was an
interesting web service we knew that
when we were looking at the web service
space that there would be plenty of
things that machines wouldn't be capable
of doing and if you were going to build
a complete application you might need to
involve humans and so Mechanical Turk
had this idea that well if you have an
API on a human you could call it and the
human could perform a task we called
them hits human interface tasks I think
was the acronym but it was very
successful we had a lot of folks doing
all kinds of things with it we did
notice that people early even early in
the machine learning space where we're
definitely using it for annotation and
that inspired us later to launch
capabilities like ground truth that took
advantage of Mechanical Turk and
specifically tailored it around the
needs of scientists to do annotation
it's um it's a super interesting area it
continues to evolve and the use of use
of Mechanical Turk interesting ideas of
using it for we've launched some things
to allow you to apply it to similar to
the original idea of Mechanical Turk to
the cases where you might have a low
confidence result and you want to put it
in front of a human and get the human to
as you decay t'what what it is so lots
of lots of stuff going on there I mean a
good example in this kovat sea
situation that we have we've had
customers using text rack to process
loan applications and what they what
they do is they look at a document and
if if text rack can't
so text track is sort of a it's a way to
think of it as optical character
recognition on steroids essentially is
looking at the whole document it can
extract patterns off the document
including forms and other things but if
for some reason you don't have high
confidence in the result we can put in
front of a human and augment the result
there so see how lots of lots of
interesting stuff there well much more
efficient process is using computer
vision to watch the Stowers throw the
stuff in bins and determine what
products are and what bins from that
eliminate a whole bunch of equipment and
motion and and improved productivity so
so yeah and they I mentioned the Amazon
Go application where people you can try
that today actually go visit an amazon
go store and and just walk out so yeah
we're super excited about what we've
what we've been able to do so far and
it's still really early there's a lot of
great stuff to to invent great thank you
so much I for the benefit of young
people in the audience who do not
remember the time before amt existed so
people like me when we wanted to get
images annotated we basically used to
conscripted graduate students to do this
and very naturally they would be tired
and sick of it so for all of you
graduate students in the audience you
have to thank empty for you not having
to do that job thank you so moving on I
want to ask a bit about your
organization and the role of computer
vision researchers in your organization
so you hired a lot of researchers into
your organization many of the prominent
people in the field and our
in Amazon so maybe you could tell us a
little bit about what's the experience
like for scientists inside Amazon and as
a follow-up question I would like to ask
you about the culture of research at
Amazon because if I compare Amazon to
companies like say Google or Facebook
there's a lot more publishing a lot more
papers coming out from your competing
labs so mm-hmm
you're all spot yeah first we serve I
think about like the first half of my
career at Amazon Amazon I don't know if
you can remember back to the 1999-2000
there are a whole bunch of stories about
how Amazon was going to go out of
business and all the big guys were gonna
take over the ecommerce future and so
Amazon's always been under tremendous
pressure to innovate and innovate
quickly and so for the first half of my
career
we were very pragmatic we focused on
what customers were telling us they
needed and what could we do to solve
those problems very quickly and as the
company became more mature we've always
had a long horizon if you think about
AWS launched in 2006 it was definitely a
long bet but we began to invest in
longer horizon research and began hiring
especially in ml we we noticed that
there was a lot of science to do if it
was gonna first of all it had tremendous
potential but there would be new science
if we were going to be able to solve
some of the problems you know the one I
mentioned with Amazon go for example it
required some really interesting
problems to be solved like you can
imagine you're trying to attract
somebody in a store and they're crying
two-year-old is at their knees so they
pick up the two-year-old and they hold
the two-year-old in their arms and now
if the two-year-olds grab so you have to
figure out disambiguate the two people
you've got two people there you have the
from things so these are these are
complicated problems and in order to
solve them there's a lot of basic
research that that needed to be done and
we began hiring scientists at Amazon we
we always had the idea that we would
publish but Amazon still has that
pragmatic streak from its beginning
where we realized that some of the most
exciting problems to work on are
problems that have applicability to the
real world and data that's associated
with the real world and that was
attracted to some scientists who wanted
access to the data in order to test new
hypothesis and and develop new
capabilities and also love the idea that
their research would actually be
embodied in some product or capability
that customers would use to better their
lives you know interestingly we've had
people go back and forth between the
academic world and the Amazon research
world and but I would say the difference
between us and and others is we always
are focused on solving a problem we're a
culture of problem solvers and we're
inspired by real-world problems which
can be very interesting to researchers
but there certainly is a strong place
for the academic world and we love
partnering certainly there are places
where you're working where the
headlights don't shine it's very hard to
even imagine the the real-world
application of the basic research that
you're you're working on and so as the
company has continued to mature its
thinking about long term research we've
continued to broaden horizon of what we
invest in both inside and outside the
company
yes that's which brings me to my next
point
because this has been the subject of a
fair amount of discussion in computer
vision in machine learning and in the
popular press they've been stories on
that in the New York Times which is that
is the current success of
ai and machine learning causing problems
for the pipeline there is this phrase
eating your seed corn so is it the case
that the success of Industry means that
industry recruits away all the other all
the top academics and then we will not
have a next generation we will not have
anybody to train sort of the PhDs and
the P and the undergraduates and
everybody else if that were to happen
that would be that would be pretty
terrible I would imagine but I greatly
it would be terrible yeah so so maybe
could you speak to that and more broadly
how how how do you engage with academia
what are you doing to sort of you know
till the soil if you will to to help the
source because academia can never
compete and salaries with what industry
can offer it cannot compete on the
amount of compute resources that
industry can offer so the question is
how do we have a balanced ecosystem
mm-hmm yeah I think the the basic answer
is that it's a partnership for the long
term I think first I would say I I don't
believe the dire that dire future you
described is is is anything close to
what will happen it's just like I
believe I don't believe that the the
that the machine learning technology is
going to take over what what humans do
and make us all obsolete I think that
you know just opens up a wonderful new
avenue for the improvement of both the
application of research and and primary
research and and discovering new things
and I think what's what we're seeing
what we see going on right now if I
think of it you know talk about this
spectrum of of how we invest in research
so we have folks on our we have an
organization model inside of AWS we call
service teams so we create teams of
people around the specific customer
problem
and and they own that problem and they
iterate really quickly and they see
customer issues and solve them quickly
and within those teams now especially in
machine learning we're assigning science
folks because there's a lot of science
that goes on and in solving these these
kinds of problems but then we also have
central science teams that are doing
sort of broader research and and
publishing some but also applying their
research out to some of these other
areas so there will be research done in
particular areas of computer vision or
natural language understanding and and
that will roll out to to the teams and
that's still often can be very we'll
call it applied science very useful for
problems that we're seeing with
customers but beyond that we also have a
set of researchers that are really there
they're part-time they will often work
for us a portion of time and then
they'll spend the majority of their time
in academia and we see that as a
wonderful pollination process both ways
the especially machine learning access
to real world data sets is extremely
useful and being able to do experiments
and see how they play out at scale is
extremely useful and so we find that
scientists love this kind of going back
and forth and we encourage our people to
do that we encourage them to go down
into service teams and learn about real
real world kind of application of
specific things and then they can go
back and and do some research inspired
by what they learned and I think the
same thing is happening across the
boundary with academia and we both share
a common goal if you truly believe in
this machine learning inspired future
where machines will be doing so many
things for us and making us so
productive it's going to require a lot
more scientists and those people are
going to be educated and they're going
to learn in the academic world and so a
healthy
world is super important to us and it's
it's why we make significant investments
in Grants and credits for researchers
for PhD students we make significant
grants for even just raw compute time
and other things for undergraduates and
we believe that we're going to have to
keep going deeper into the educational
system in order to bring students into
this incredibly important area from the
very start and so that's a partnership
with academia we think it's really
important and as I said we'll we'll
partner with we're not in no way are we
going to want to or or would ever be
able to but but would want to remove the
capability of academic institutions to
both do research and to bring up the the
number of folks that are going to be
needed for this area Thanks so yeah
maybe you could elaborate a little bit
on the the program you have for
supporting compute at universities
because in practical terms this is one
of the things that is difficult for
faculty and grad students they simply
don't have access to the kind of compute
that is needed today for doing
cutting-edge research and I think it's
not just an issue for for Amazon alone
it's really I think we have to figure
out a solution at the level of the
federal government Amazon and the
universities a solution which will help
support the ecosystem but that's a topic
for a longer discussion but if you had
anything to say
from your perspective yeah well you know
we do have we have specific programs in
place with you know major universities
on research funded research as as well
as these sort of part-time back and
forth programs where were
bringing folks in in and and having them
do funded funded research on directive
things that that we problems that we see
and need to have solved and we're doing
that with Carnegie Mellon MIT Stanford
Berkeley is very portable there and in a
number of schools and each of these
schools if I would encourage folks that
are listening we have we have specific
programs in place and look the cloud is
has created a wonderful opportunity to
just as it's done for startups where you
know I had an interesting conversation
with venture capitalists back in 2009 I
was visiting the Silicon Valley and I
wanted to talk to some of the companies
that were in the portfolio of this
venture capitalists and the venture
capitalists said you know over lunch she
said you know you're disrupting our our
business and I said how are we
disrupting your business and he couldn't
be with disrupting you he said well
because you guys make it so cheap for
people to try out new ideas we used to
be able to go to these companies and
they needed our money and so we would
get a piece of the company but now we're
going to companies and they're telling
us well I run my infrastructure off my
credit card and I already have 18
million customers why do I need you and
what was very inspiring for me by that
with that conversation was the idea that
there were so many new ideas that were
being funded and were happening because
the the accessibility of of just this
raw compute infrastructure and
everything else was just it was so much
easier and cheaper to get a hold of it
and so I think that's what we've been
able to do to it with academia is to
reduce the cost and and then to make
available some of these programs cuz
it's in everyone's interest to become
educated on on the tools and to have
access to the resources to to do the
research so so just by making this stuff
so much cheaper and easier to get at and
in fact one of the areas that I'm I am
very excited to see papers and
other kinds of research is is you know
humans are tool builders
we're very you that that's that's what's
differentiated us and and I see so much
coming out where of our universities and
environment of great tools that are
further going to accelerate research and
remove some of the boring heavy lifting
from getting things done just as
Mechanical Turk removed the boring heavy
lifting of annotation from you guys yes
so maybe we can now move to a slightly
broader question which is on computer
vision as a whole and across multiple
businesses and the reason I ask is and
somebody who's been in the field for
many years and for many years computer
vision was purely an academic discipline
we wrote papers we talked to each other
who wrote papers and we discussed our
last paper as it most of what we tried
wasn't good enough to work in practice
now that has changed and that's why we
have so much of computer vision now
happening in in an industry both
research and development and product
ization
so from your perspective can you speak
to how you think computer vision
technology will play out across the
board I mean Amazon is in many
businesses so you probably have a
perspective on this yeah well well first
we're seeing it explode across the board
in and what it can be applied to as I
mentioned Amazon go we also we have a
capability of delivering packages called
prime air that entirely depends on
computer vision I know there are folks
that are working on the problem as you
know sort of human managed drones that
would deliver things but fundamentally
if you're going to scale delivery to
Amazon scale and make it possible to do
airdrop delivery in your backyard almost
anywhere you fundamentally need
autonomous vehicles in the air and the
only way that people are going to accept
a bunch of autonomous drones flying
around as if they're incredibly safe
what actually one of my favorites is
there's a gentleman who who created had
a problem his cat kept bringing home
dead animals I don't know if you've seen
this Qi Tantra but the the cat would
would bring a dead animal in in the
middle of the night and of course this
was very upsetting to the household and
he thought for a moment he said well
wait a minute I believe computer vision
might be able to solve my problem and so
what he did is he got a little Arduino
board with an actuator that could could
both the the cat door closed and he he
got one of our deep cams
we have a camera that we we created to
help educate people on computer vision
it's it's a little kit you can get off
Amazon and comes with some deep learning
capability that you can you can trade
models with and so he he trained models
to first recognize when the cat was
coming to the door and then recognized
whether the cat had an animal in its
mouth whether he had a dead animal in
smell and so his serial killer cat could
be spotted trying to come back to the
house he even built his program so that
every time the cat got came back and got
locked out couldn't bring the dead
animal in the house he would send money
to the Audubon Society as sort of a
payment for having killed that animal
but the point is computer vision is
becoming so much more accessible to so
many more people and I think we're going
to see you know within our company with
our customers you know we see it being
used by so many customers for for
different applications
it can be used in industrial settings to
look at a the quality of things coming
down a line there's this very
interesting case of finding trafficking
human trafficking and and basically
saving people from situations that the
that are just horrible and and there's
some wonderful stories of people being
rescued through computer
vision technology so it's very exciting
time I think for for how this will be
applied it's it's wonderful to see the
growth of the space so what are some of
the major trends in computer vision that
you see impacting the field right now ah
well it's a great question I think the
first would be or we're definitely going
to need better benchmarking and open
standards in computer vision we're
seeing increasing need to earn trust and
you know sample I I I used to work with
my daughter when she was she was
studying machine machine learning and
she was doing some computer vision
assignments and I remember being very
impressed with the deep neural networks
and what they could do but they were
entirely unexplainable I as a computer
scientist I thought well but you know I
I have no idea what's going on inside of
that black box and I think what we're
seeing in in the industry is that in
order for machine learning computer
vision specifically to be more trusted
in what it's doing we need we need good
benchmarks and public and open standards
so the technology can be validated I
think another important area is
accessibility as the demand is quickly
outstripping the supply of the people
who can develop models and deploy the
technology we're going to need much
better tools that enable the average
person average software engineer or even
end-user to be able to to get at the
technology and to deploy it I did talk
about that a little bit earlier but I
think it's a super under is super
important point to underscore and then I
think another one is they you know we've
often thought about computer vision is
something that just does things on its
own but we're we're going to have to
think of it in
tandem with human capabilities and so
better integration of humans in the loop
and both let the let the computer vision
do the boring dangerous things that we
don't want humans doing and then keep
the humans into the in the in the loop
too to help us with accuracy and and
collaborate really with this new
technology great I want you to ask you
about applications from their customer
perspective are there any which have
really surprised you oh wow
well I have to say it's it is definitely
one of those across-the-board things you
know it's they're just all over the
place and in so many different
industries and so many you know it we've
it's just that the broad range of how
people are applying it I'd say you know
example is delivery using it for content
moderation so you know making sure that
the things that belong funded people are
are there and things that don't art and
into it actually uses computer vision to
help the customers file their taxes
faster and more efficiently the NFL uses
it to do real-time analytics and to
monitor players for health and safety we
recently announced the World Wildlife
Federation is using computer vision to
better understand the size and health of
orangutan populations and endangered
species so and then of course I think I
mentioned this before in the kovat
endemic we have right now employing it
to to see who might be sick coming into
an environment is is interesting and
it's amazing how fast people have moved
to deploy computer vision as a solution
to this urgent crisis great I want to
close out with an important question
given the time we are in and given the
time when this interview is being
conducted so diversity and inclusion
have been important concerns for the
technology industry in general and
specifically for AI and machine learning
so would you like to say something about
what Amazon is doing in this direction
sure well first of all I've been in
Amazon 22 years and it's always been one
of the most diverse environments in the
world from my perspective and the
company has always been proponent and a
recognizer that viewpoints from all
different corners come together to give
you better ideas and so we've we've
always believed in that and and we
continue to invest in improving the
engagement of of different groups I
think a super important thing we can all
work on is is education we need to work
on bringing more people from diverse
backgrounds into machine learning and
computer vision
I'm software engineering in general I
mean we just we basically need to
increase the participation and we also I
would point out you know inside of our
computers and machine learning teams we
have an amazingly diverse team of folks
it's it's a it's a technology that I
think I think benefits from worldwide
involvement we've seen we have offices
all over the world and and bringing
people in to our our technical
organization from the
backgrounds has really helped us build
better products we sponsor and host
events such you know for code.org as an
example girls who code we partnered with
the Nita Borg Institute to sponsor
events like the great Grace Hopper
celebration for women in computing and
we also helped students enroll in
national programs like aspirations in
computing so it's super important we
believe training the next generation of
leaders indeed and I hope that this is
an inspiration to all the students in
the audience because there are frontiers
for computer vision have really expanded
in the last several years and that's
wonderful so as a closing question I
want to go a bit bigger picture and
philosophical and this is a question
from the audience and let's put some
context here I mean there is in the
popular press a lot of discussion about
AI and the impact of AI and this ranges
from all those all the fears of oh there
will be this AGI it will run amok decide
whether or not to bother with the human
race anymore and so on and there is that
that at one extreme and then there are
the fears about unemployment at another
issue the issues with biases cetera et
cetera so what I'd like is your from a
very practical and pragmatic point of
view what do you think will be the
consequences of AI in the next few years
is it the next Industrial Revolution
what will what do you think what do you
see in the future um I do I do think it
is the next Industrial Revolution you
know if I think about you know what we
did with the cloud that was a revolution
but I I think it may end up when we look
back a thousand years from now being
dwarfed
by the revolution happening in nai and
machine learning it's look it has this
tremendous potential to better our lives
it I you know people go back and look at
history and each time we came up with
things that make make our lives better
and more productive they've been
beneficial to the human race there have
been no examples of a new technology
that enabled productivity the way ml and
AI can do and and you had a bad result
so I'm very optimistic I think we're
going to see tremendous improvements in
human productivity which is better for
all it it will it essentially will lower
the cost of getting anything and anytime
you lower the cost of getting it you get
a lot more opportunity it's not it's not
a constraint so I am super optimistic
about it I am NOT an evil AI kind of
type I believe that will will continue
to develop
AI in a positive way and it's because
it's heritage will be positive great so
Johnny you don't think the future of AI
is that doc is it no I I think if you
look at human history it's just it's
very clear that as you get advances like
this that improve human productivity
everyone benefits and I think first of
all there's been no advancement like
this this is this is machine
intelligence and it's what what
differentiates humans from animals and
now machines will be able to do things
for us that are mundane and boring and
and free us to do all kinds of new
things and so I believe it's a we're
kind of at the dawn of a wonderful new
era in human capability
and machine learning will make that
possible and I think that there are
those who say oh you know there will be
evil a eyes and and it's there's nothing
nothing evil evolves from the kind of
good that were we're asking them to do
for us and in fact you would get into an
interesting debate have been in these
before about about how a eyes can evolve
but but I'm very optimistic about the
sort of history of how development of
new productive capabilities for humans
has has benefited us in the large and
and I believe for sure that's what's
gonna happen with machine we're already
seeing it I mean I'm seeing all kinds of
different applications where you know as
I mentioned you know stopping human
trafficking or benefits Vick Ovid or
there's there are companies applying
this to to recognizing all kinds of
situations and responding to them and I
just think it's going to be a boon to
humankind as as we deploy this further
and it'll free us up to do things that
aren't repetitive and and useless
wonderful Thank You charlie it's been a
pleasure chatting with you and on behalf
of the computer vision community and
cvpr 20/20 I want to thank you for
taking the time and sharing your
insights about from your vantage point
at Amazon I wish that we were in a real
physical environment and you could have
heard all the claps so now you just have
to imagine it virtually but thanks again
and it's been a pleasure and that day
will be upon us soon
and a quick machine learning will get us
there so thank you machine learning is
going to continue to improve the lives
of truck drivers using computer vision
machine learning we wanted to see if we
could
an automatic analysis of autism and
autism spectrum disorder machine
learning allows us to get very very
quickly to very complex data machine
learning can actually directly
contribute to understanding our planet
[Music]
we can use machine learning and computer
vision analysis to assess things like
facial expression and attention and so
we built a set of movies that elicit
these behaviors and use the camera in
the device to measure the child's
response
[Music]
AWS is allowing us to go through the
machine learning phase together and we
can now predict future performance based
on the data of the past
[Music]
the innovation that convoyed has brought
is we can figure out where the right
truck is for the right load anywhere in
the country and using machine learning
match the right trucker at the right
price to move a shipment from point A to
point B
we sail around Antarctica in 196 days
with three vehicles you will need to
understand the risk of collision with
icebergs which can be the size of small
countries drones are equipped with
cameras the problem being when you had
seen the ocean moves the waves move and
we need to train machine learning
algorithms so we can navigate it
[Music]
how do we use the technology that we
have developed and put it at the service
of the planet we're embracing machine
learning we're embracing AI we're gonna
truly change the game I'd like to have
old time because I don't get a lot of
time alone
but that's what the convoy app does will
be it helps me be horrible if we can do
just a small thing to change one kids I
think I would go to sleep with a smile
[Music]
you
[Music]